ايضا نشيل الخبر العاجل نقل عن معاريف عن
اطلاق اكثر من 70 صاروخ من القطاع باتجاه
مستوطنات غلاف غزه منذ صباح اليوم وكذلك
نقلا عن مراسل الجزيره صافرات الانذار
تدوي في مستوطنات نيروز ونيريوم عند
المنطقه الوسطى المتاخمه لقطاع غزه والى
المتابعه لهذه الصور المباشره اعود الى
هشام زقوط من قطاع غزه ومعه نرصد اخر
المستجدات وكيف هو الوضع في هذه اللحظات
[موسيقى]
بالفعل عبد القادر الوضع حتى الان يمكن ان
نقول انه يسود هدوء يعني حذر في قطاع غزه
لم نشهد خلال ربما العشر دقائق او ربع
ساعه الماضيه اي غارات اسرائيليه على اي
من المواقع في قطاع غزه او الاهداف ست
مواقع تتبع للمقاومه الفلسطينيه تم
استهدافها من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وطائرات الاستطلاع اعنف
الغارات
مواقع وليس خمسه هشام موقع
ست مواقع بالفعل الموقع الاخير في شمال
قطاع غزه والذي تحدثنا عنه قبل نحو ربع
ساعه كان هو الموقع السادس الذي تم
استهدافه
المواقع اغلبها في شمال قطاع غزه وايضا في
غرب مدينه غزه في مخيم الشاطئ غرب مدينه
غزه وايضا في جنوب غرب مدينه غزه موقع
البيدر التابع للمقاومه وايضا في جنوب
قطاع غزه في خان يونس استهدف احد مواقع
المقاومه هناك اذا ست مواقع للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه تم استهدافها من غارات
اسرائيليه ومن طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه
وايضا طائرات استطلاع اسرائيليه اعنف هذه
الغارات تلك التي استهدفت موقع بدر في
مخيم الشاطئ غرب مدينه غزه وهو المخيم
الاقرب الى مدينه غزه وهو المخيم الاكثر
اكتظاظا ربما بالسكان او احد اكثر
المخيمات اقتضاضا في السكان في قطاع غزه
وقطاع غزه نحن نتحدث عن قطاع صغير هو
الاعلى كثافه سكانيه في العالم ربما
وهناك قصف لهذه المواقع تناثرت الشظايا
الى مسافات بعيده وتصاعدت السنه اللهب
واعمده الدخان من هذه المواقع وهناك اضرار
جسيمه في المواقع المستهدفه وايضا في
المنازل القريبه من هذه المواقع وكان هناك
حديث عن
الشظايا وصلت الى منازل المواطنين في مخيم
الشاطئ جراء القصف العنيف الذي استهدف هذا
الموقع القريب من هذه المنازل اربع غارات
اسرائيليه او اربع صواريخ من طائرات حربيه
اسرائيليه قصفت هذا الموقع بخلاف الصواريخ
الاستطلاع الذي التي استهدفت
بالتالي الشظايا تطايرت الى منازل
المواطنين وهناك اضرار جسيمه في المخيم
طيب